ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAKES NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA BARRICADE HEN BENNETT.
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BURKE
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAO
JUNE CHIU CHOI COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY DAVIES
LARA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY BLACKIE. LEE
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA. WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK BURKE SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS MOOSE RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY OUR TUNE
SMITH. SOON D. MELENDEZ VIA
FOOD LAW VOEPEL WALDRON LORD
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THESE PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YASIR KHAN IMAM YASIR. IN THE
NAME OF GOD THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. OH GOD. YOU
HAVE GIVEN US THE FREEDOM TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN GOOD AND EVIL.
ALLOW US TO REMAIN STEADFAST TO
CHOOSE A GOOD FOR OUR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT TOMORROW'S
GENERATION MAY INHERIT FROM US
THE BLESSINGS OF DIGNITY AND
FREEDOM. PROSPERITY AND PEACE.
MAY THIS BE GOD'S WILL I MEAN.
THANK YOU MY S. HERE YES OUR
GUESTS VISITORS REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TANK AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER TAKE. MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. TO THE FLAG.
IT'S A- INTO. WHICH IS AN- ONE
ASIAN- INDIVIDUAL. STRONG.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED READING
OF THE DAY'S JOURNAL GO TO ONCE
A MONDAY DECEMBER SAID TWENTY
PER TO THE PER OF THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE SENATE THE
OUR TOOL THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO SESSION OF THE CAL
LEGISLATURE CALLED OR BY SUPER.
CHIEF CLERK SIMPLY FOR TWENTY
NINE TWENTY REGULAR SESSION A
CONFORMING WITH A LOT OF OFF
ARE ALSO PRESENT AB LEADS
MEDICAL IS RAMOS MOVE AND MISS
FLOOR SAY. THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE THIS
WITH PRESIDENT AND BRITISH
THERE ARE NONE AND REFER OF
BILLS BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
WILL BE READ. AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED. MESSAGES FOR THE
GOVERNOR. THERE ARE NONE IN.
FROM THIS. THERE ARE NONE
MOVING HIM AND- THE AB FOR THE
DAY. FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY WALL.
FOR MEN LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
FRAZIER. ANCOR. MS RAY YOU ARE
FOR PROCEDURAL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST YOU
KNOW CONSENT TO THE RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM IS
AREA AND WE'RE ALMOST READY IS
THROUGH. COOPER TEEING BY
SPEAKER RENDON GIPSON AND
MEDINA TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. MISTER SPEAKER
PERCENT ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY ONE
FOUR POINT ONE. FIFTY ONE I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
REFER S. B. TWENTY NINE
NUMBERED TO THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
MEMBERS A QUICK
ANNOUNCEMENT. TODAY'S ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH BIRTHDAY
WHEN YOU SEE TASHA PLEASE WISH
HER A HAPPY BIRTHDAY. MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS. LET'S KEEP THE VOLUME
LEVEL IN THE CHAMBER MANAGEABLE
MEMBERS WE ARE AT THE THIRD
READING FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER. ONE MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS TO. THREE AND. FOUR
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND
YOU AT THIS TIME OF THE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE A
REQUIREMENTS ON THE FLOOR OF
THE ASSEMBLY. I SEE A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS HAPPENING MEMBERS
PLEASE KEEP. MINDFUL OF
PHYSICAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE THIS IS H. R.
THIRTEEN. THE CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION THIRTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO TOM
FLORES. MISTER GARCIA. WE WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY.
WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR MR GARCIA TASHA
BOERNER HORVATH HAS ENTERED THE
CHAMBER HAPPY BIRTHDAY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN BOERNER HORVATH. WAS A
GREAT TIME KILLER MR GARCIA YOU
MAY NOW OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES IT'S A
WITH GREAT HONOR THAT I COME
BEFORE YOU. TO ASK THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZED TOM THE ICEMAN
FLORES WHO IS THE FIRST. MEDINA
QUARTERBACK OF- MEXICAN DESCENT
THE FIRST LATINO HEAD COACH IN
THE FIRST. MEDINA PRESIDENT TO
EVER HAD A PROFESSIONAL
FOOTBALL TEAM AND YES. A
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AND I'LL
ELABORATE A BIT MORE TO BE MORE
SPECIFIC WHERE HE WAS FROM HE
WAS BORNIN NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN. IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY TO FARMWORKER PARENTS
WHO WERE ORIGINALLY FROM G.
WHILE I MAKE PEOPLE. DURING HIS
COLLEGE CAREER THE ICEMAN WAS
RANKED IN THE TOP TEN OF
PASSERS IN NINETEEN FIFTY SIX
AND NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY TOM SIGNED WITH
THE AFL'S OAKLAND RAIDERS.
MAKING BARRIERS FROM FIRST
LATINO BECOMING THE FIRST
NOTHING A QUARTERBACK AND
FOOTBALL. TOM WAS NAME EIGHT.
STAR IN MY SIXTIES AND WENT ON
TO WIN SUPER BOWL WITH THE
KANSAS CITY CHIEFS IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY. RETIRING AFTER THIS
SEASON. HIS FIFTH LEADING HE
BECAME THE FIFTH LEADING PASSER
IN AFL HISTORY IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO HE BECAME THE
ASSISTANT COACH OF THE OAKLAND
RAIDERS. AND WAS INSTRUMENTAL
TAKING THEM TO A WINNING SUPER
BOWL IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN.
THE ICEMAN WAS SELECTED TO BE
THE HEAD COACH OF THE RAIDERS
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE
BREAKING ANOTHER BARRIER. THE
COMING NOT JUST THE FIRST
LATINO HEAD COACH BUT ALSO THE
FIRST MINORITY. HEAD COACH IN
PRO FOOTBALL PERIOD. AS HEAD
COACH TOM FLORES LED THE
RAIDERS TO A SUPER BOWL VICTORY
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE. TOM
REMAIN WITH THE TEAM AFTER THEY
RELOCATED TO LOS ANGELES IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO AND WON
ANOTHER SUPER BOWL IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR. LET THE RECORD
SHOW THAT TOM FLORES HAS WON
MORE CHAMPIONSHIPS FOR THE
RAIDERS THAN ANY OTHER RELIGION
OUT THERE. INCLUDING JOHN
MADDEN LITTLE TRIVIA THAT FOLKS
DON'T KNOW ABOUT. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT TOP FLOORS WAS
NAMED PRESIDENT AND GM OF THE
SEAHAWKS AGAIN BEING THE FIRST
LATINO OF MEXICAN DESCENT. TO
HOLD THIS POSITION. TOM IS ONE
OF ONLY TWO PEOPLE IN THE NFL
HISTORY TO WIN A SUPER BOWL AS
A PLAYER. ASSISTANT COACH AND
HEAD COACH. THE OTHER LITTLE
TRIVIA AGAIN WAS MY DICK THAT.
THE ICE MAN CURRENTLY RESIDES
IN THE BEAUTIFUL COACHELLA
VALLEY AND REMAINS AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE RAIDERS
COMMUNITY. DESPITE HIS
LEGENDARY CAREER AS A PLAYER
COACH IN THE FRONT OFFICE AND
MOST RECENTLY AS A PLAY BY PLAY
COMMENTATOR. TOM IS ONE OF ONLY
FOUR COACHES TO WIN MULTIPLE
SUPER BOWLS WAS NOT ALREADY. IN
THE HALL OF FAME. COMMUNITY
SUPPORT FLORES HAS BEEN GROWING.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ENSURING THAT THIS
YEAR HE IS INDUCTED INTO THE
HALL OF FAME. SEVERAL CITY
COUNCILS HAVE RECENTLY WEIGHED
IN IN SUPPORT OF MR FLOORS
INDUCTION BY APPROVING
RESOLUTIONS INCLUDING LOS
ANGELES FRESNO YOU'RE ON. AN
INCLUDING MR FLORES'S HOMETOWN
SANGER CALIFORNIA. TOP STORIES
IS THE LIVING NFL LEGEND AND A
TRUE INSPIRATION FOR MANY
LATINO OF MEXICAN DESCENT YOUTH
AND FAMILIES ACROSS OUR NATION.
FLOORS A PAIN IN MY EYES. THE
GREATNESS OF WHAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE IN THIS COUNTRY AND IN
THE BEAUTIFUL STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AGAIN CHASING WHAT
IS WE CALL THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM. THERE IS NO REASON WHY
AFTER A LIFETIME OF OUTSTANDING
ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN THE NFL THE
HE SHOULDN'T FINALLY BE
INDUCTED THIS YEAR. WITH THIS
RESOLUTION WE WANT TO LET THE
WORLD KNOW THAT TOM FLORES HAS
SUPPORT FROM HIS STATE LEADERS
TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE OF THIS
RESOLUTION TO URGE THE HALL OF
FAME. COMMITTEE TO RECTIFY THIS
OVERSIGHT I PAYING HOMAGE TO
THE LEGACY OF THIS TRAILBLAZER
TO NOT JUST THE LATINO
COMMUNITY BUT ALL MINORITIES
AND INDUCTED INTO THE HALL OF
FAME COLLEAGUES I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF HR THIRTY. THANK YOU
MISTER GARCIA MISTER VIA PUT A-
BIGGER. I STAND AS OF HOUSE
THIRTEEN. TO URGE THE INDUCTION
HAVE A GREAT UNIVERSITY OF
PACIFIC ALUMNI. MISTER THOMPSON
LAWRENCE. INTO THE NATIONAL
FOOTBALL LEAGUE HALL OF FAME B.
REYES IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY BY
TWO IMMIGRANT FARM WORKERS
MISTER FLORES STORY. SERVICE AT
LEAST TRUE INSPIRATION FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS IT IS ONE OF
OVERCOMING BARRIERS AND NEVER
GIVING UP. DESPITE THE
SUCCESSFUL COLLEGIATE CAREER AS
A QUARTERBACK HE WENT
UNDEFEATED 75% OF HIS GAMES.
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF PACIFIC.
IN MY HOME TOWN OF STOCKTON AND
NOW RECEIVING A AND NOT NOT
RECEIVING A SINGLE OFFER FROM A
TEAM TO PLAY IN THE NFL HE WENT
TO PLAY FOR THE CANADIAN
FOOTBALL LEAGUE HE LATER
RETURNED TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
TO PLAY FOR THE SEMI PRO TEAM
IN BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA
SPOILERS. NEVER GIVING UP ON
HIS DREAM TO PLAY IN THE NFL.
ON HIS THIRD ATTEMPT TO SIGN
WITH THE PROFESSIONAL TEAM HE
WAS FINALLY OFFERED A SPOT TO
PLAY IN THE OAKLAND RAIDERS
WHERE HE'S LUCK BEGAN TO
CHANGE. TOM POOREST CAREER IN
THE NFL WAS NOTHING SHORT OF A
TRAILBLAZER. MISTER FLORES
BECAME THE LEAGUE'S FIRST
LATINO QUARTERBACK AND-
EVENTUALLY THE FIRST LATINO
HEAD COACH PRESIDENT AND
GENERAL MANAGER OF THE TEAM.
HIS CAREER IS DECORATED WITH
FOUR SUPER BOWL TITLES AS A
PLAYER COACH THREE OF THEM
WHICH CAME DURING THIS TIME AS
A RAIDER. MISTER FLORES HAS
BEEN NOMINATED AS A FINALIST
FOR THE HALL OF FAME. THREE
YEARS IN A ROW BUT STILL IS
WAITING CONFIRMATION IT IS TIME
WE CHANGE THAT. I THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM COACHELLA FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD AND URGE A YES VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANKS FOR DOCTOR RAMBLER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I AM SO PLEASED
TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUES FROM
COACHELLA AS WELL AS STOCKTON
IN HR THIRTEEN. NOW TOM FLORES
BETTER KNOWN AS ICEMAN IS FROM
FRESNO COUNTY SPECIFICALLY HE
WAS BORN IN DEL RAYO SMALL
UNINCORPORATED AREA BEFORE YOU
MOVED TO SANGER AT THE AGE OF
FOUR. HE WANTS TO HIGH SCHOOL
AND WAS A PATCHY AND SINGER
WHERE HE PLAYED QUARTERBACK AND
GRABBED ANYTHING HE COULD WHILE
WORKING IN THE FIELDS TO HELP
HIM IN HIS PURSUIT OF. HIS
DETERMINATION TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN FOOTBALL. BUT IT WAS
ACTUALLY AT SANGER THAT HE DID
NOT GET THE PRE REQUISITE
CLASSES TO ENTER INTO A FOUR
YEAR DEGREE THAT HE THEN WENT
TO FRESNO CITY COLLEGE WHERE WE
WERE PLEASED TO HAVE HIM AS
AROUND WHERE HE WAS OUR STORE
QUARTERBACK BEFORE HE WENT. TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF PACIFIC.
WHILE HE HAS BEEN AN EXEMPLARY
ROLE MODEL FOR SO MANY LATINOS
IT IS HIS HARD WORK HIS
DETERMINATION THAT ULTIMATELY
WILL BE HIS LEGACY FOR SO MANY
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO PURSUE
THEIR LIFE DREAMS TOM FLORES
THE ICEMAN HAS BEEN THE EXAMPLE
IN THE CENTRAL SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY I AM PLEASED TO JOIN
TODAY'S HR THIRTEEN AND HOPE
THAT THIS IS THE YEAR THAT HE
GETS INDUCTED. INTO THE HALL OF
FAME. THANK YOU DR RAMBLER.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. MR GARCIA YOU MAKE
CALLS IF YOU WISH THANK YOU TO
MY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE STOOD UP
AND WAITED ON THE MATTER RIGHT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A BLACK
AND SILVER FAN TO RECOGNIZE THE
FACT THAT THE THIS INDIVIDUAL
HAS WORKED TIRELESSLY HEARTED
BROKEN TOO MANY BARRIERS- TO BE
AT A PLACE WHERE TODAY WE ASK
THAT THE HALL OF FAME INDUCTEE
IN FOR HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS. AND
SO I JUST WANTED TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE IDEA CAME FROM- ONE OF
OUR FORMER COLLEAGUES WHO HAD
APPROACHED US- COUNTY
SUPERVISOR LUIS ALEJO AND SAID
YOU KNOW THIS GUY LIVES IN YOUR
BACKYARD HE'S FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT
THE HALL OF FAME RECOGNIZE HIM
FOR HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS I
WANTED JUST TO GIVE SUPERVISORS
ALEJO'S SOME KUDOS FOR BRINGING
THIS TO OUR ATTENTION AND I
WANT TO JUST QUOTE. MR FLOOR AS
IN A RECENT ARTICLE THAT WAS
PRINTED IN THE LOCAL PAPER THEY
ASKED HIM HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
THIS THIRD NOMINATION AND HE
SAID YOU KNOW MY HOPES AREN'T
VERY HIGH ON THIS THIRD
NOMINATION HE SAYS HOWEVER I
KNOW THAT MY. ACCOMPLISHMENTS
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES. AND AT A
YOUNG. FROM THE- CENTRAL VALLEY
WHOSE PARENTS CAME TO WORK IN
THE FIELDS LIKE MANY STORIES
THAT WE'VE HEARD ON THIS
ASSEMBLY FLOOR CAME HERE AND
WERE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH. THEIR
DREAMS WHICH WAS TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEIR FAMILY
AND THAT I WAS ABLE TO ACHIEVE
MY DREAM THAT IN ITSELF IS THE
HALL OF FAME- FOR ME IN WHETHER
OR NOT I ENTER THE HALL OF FAME
IS UP TO A COMMITTEE IN ITSELF
BUT- I DO HOPE THAT ON. THAT
I'M AROUND TO HAVE A PARTY IF I
DO GET INTO THE HALL OF FAME
HE'S EIGHTY NINE YEARS OLD
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR HR THIRTEEN AND THAT THIS
YEAR HE GETS INTO THE HALL OF
FAME THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. AND MISTER SEA WOULD
YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON PERSON
ROLE FOR- COOPER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. MACARTHUR'S THIS
IS BECAUSE. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS JUSTICE FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSER ALL THERE
ARE SIXTY SIX CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS. WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
MEMBERS. OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE GREEN
CRPET AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS SO WE
MAY PROCEED. OR REMOVE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS READ A PRIOR PERMISSION
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THEY DO ASK THAT THIS
BODY ADJOURNMENT OF. FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CACHO SAJJAN.
AND IT WASN'T JUST A FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHO'S A FORMER
COUNTY SUPERVISOR A FAMILY MAN
BUSINESSMAN. IN A TRUE AMERICAN
AND CALIFORNIAN SUCCESS STORY.
CACCIA WAS BORN IN LEBANON IN
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE. HE MERRY TO
ROXY THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR THEY WERE
BLESSED WITH TWO INCREDIBLE
KIDS GARAGE AND IRENE. HE
IMMIGRATED TO SAN LUIS OBISPO
CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
ONE ATTENDING CUESTA COLLEGE
AND CAL POLY. WE'RE GRADUATED
WITH A DEGREE IN BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION. DURING COLLEGE
SHE WORKED AT A SHELL GAS
STATION. WHERE HE HONED HIS
PEOPLE SKILLS AND HIS BUSINESS
SKILLS EVER THE PRACTICAL MIND.
EVENTUALLY CATCH A BOAT THAT
GAS STATION FROM THE OWNERS
ACQUIRED ANOTHER ONE. UNTIL THE
THIRD ONE FROM THE GROUND UP.
CACHO EVENTUALLY WAS DRAWN BY
HIS INCREDIBLE PASSION FOR THE
COMMUNITY TO PUBLIC SERVICE. HE
RAN FOR COUNTY SUPERVISOR WHERE
HE SERVED FOR TWELVE YEARS
THREE FOUR YEAR TERMS.
ACCOMPLISH MORE THAN WE CAN
EVEN DISCUSS IN A SHORTER
JOURNEY MEMORY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AND OUR COUNTY. THEN
HE RAN FOR STATE ASSEMBLY WHERE
HE SERVED WITH MANY OF. OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THIS BODY FOR SIX
YEARS. UNTIL IT WAS TURNED OUT.
HE WAS WITHOUT A DOUBT THE MOST
BELOVED POLITICAL FIGURE IN SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNTY USE
PRAGMATIC. HE WAS A CONSENSUS
BUILDER HE WAS A GENTLEMAN. HE
WAS ALSO MY MENTOR. I REMEMBER
WHEN I FIRST APPROACH KOCH
ABOUT RUNNING FOR HIS SEAT WHEN
HE TURNED OUT HE GAVE ME TWO
PIECES OF ADVICE HE SAID FIRST.
MAKE SURE YOUR WIFE'S A 100% ON
BOARD. AND HE SAID SECOND. IF
YOU DO IT. GET IN EARLY AND GO
FULL THROTTLE. AS I THINK ABOUT
IT THAT' PRETTY DARN GOOD
DECISION MAKING LIFE FOREVER
FOR ANYTHING MAKE SURE IT'S
RIGHT FOR YOUR FAMILY AND IF
YOU DO IT. GO FULL THROTTLE. HE
WAS ALWAYS FAMILY FIRST. THERE
ARE MANY CALLS AND LUNCH IS
OVER THE YEARS. DURING MANY
CIGAR SMOKING SESSIONS OVER THE
YEARS. HE ALWAYS EVERY TIME WE
MET HE ASKED ABOUT MY FAMILY
FIRST. HOW SHAUNA ARE THE KIDS
YOU TALK ABOUT FAMILY. WE TALK
ABOUT OUR MUTUAL LOVE FOR CARS.
AND THEN WE DID EVENTUALLY GET
AROUND TO POLITICS BUT
SOMETIMES WE NEVER DID. I TELL
YOU WHAT HE LOVED PEOPLE HE
ALWAYS PUT PEOPLE FIRST.
WHENEVER WE TALK ABOUT THE
ASSEMBLY READ ASKING WHAT WAS
GOING ON HE ASKED ME ABOUT. YOU
GUYS. HIS FORMER COLLEAGUES.
HEY HOW'S COOPER DOING HAS JIM
WOOD. HOW'S SPEAKER. HE WAS
WITHOUT A DOUBT THE MOST
NONPARTISAN PERSON I'VE EVER
MET IN ELECTED OFFICE. HE WAS A
CONSENSUS BUILDER. HE CAME FROM
A COUNTRY THAT WAS TORN APART
BY WAR AND I BELIEVE I BELIEVE
THAT THAT CAUSED HIM TO ALWAYS
SEEK PEACE FIRST. AND HE TOOK
THAT INTO EVERYTHING HE DID
LIFE. HE WAS ABOUT OUR
COMMUNITY. HE FUNDED STARTED
FIRST FIVE MINUTES IN THE
SPECIFIC. YEP ON THE FOOD BANK
MEALS ON WHEELS WE'RE WAS A
NEED CULTURE ACTION ALWAYS WITH
HIS DOLLARS WITH THIS TIME.
YEAH BOUNDLESS ENERGY. I
REMEMBER MEETING WITH THE LOW
MAYOR WHEN I WAS FOR RUNNING
FOR THE ASSEMBLY HE SAID WELL
YOU GOTTA BE LIKE TAX YOU KNOW
YOU GOT TO GO TO A THE
QUANTITIES IN ROTARY YOU GOT TO
BE EVERYWHERE THE- KOCH'S YOUR
MODEL. I SAID WELL I DON'T HAVE
ENERGY SO WE NEED TO PLAY B.
THAT'S NOT WORK. HE WAS.
WITHOUT A DOUBT THE MOST NON
PART. ELECTED OFFICEHOLDER I'VE
EVER MET. HE VIEWED THE WORLD
NOT IN TERMS OF PARTISANSHIP.
BUT IN TERMS OF PEOPLE THAT
COULD BE HELPED. AND PROBLEMS
THAT COULD BE SOLVED. HE WAS
DEEPLY PATRIOTIC. HE WITH THE
AMERICAN DREAM. HE GAVE BACK TO
HIS COMMUNITY AND HIS COUNTRY.
SO I ASKED WE ADJOURNMENT
REPROACH. THERE WILL NEVER BE
ANOTHER LIKE HIM. MAY WE ALL
LEARN FROM HIS EXAMPLE. THANK
YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM. MISTER
NAJARIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
COLLEGES WITH GREAT SADNESS
THAT I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY. OF CULTURE CHARGIN A
BUSINESS OWNER AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL AND A COMMUNITY
LEADER. AND VOLUNTEER. FOR MANY
HE'LL BE REMEMBERED AS A
QUINTESSENTIAL AMERICAN SUCCESS
STORY BUT TO THOSE OF US CLOSE
TO HIM AND WHO HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. GET ACQUAINTED
WITH THEM. THROUGH OUR
RESPECTIVE CAREERS AND LINES OF
WORK HE WAS A FRIEND AND A
MENTOR. BORN IN JALALABAD
LEBANON IN NINETEEN FIFTY ONE
TO ARMENIAN PARENTS A JUDGE AND
IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED STATES
IN SEVENTY ONE. WHERE HE WOULD
EVENTUALLY NEED HIS LIFE
PARTNER AT OXY. CONTINUE HIS
EDUCATION AND BECOME A
SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS OWNER. HE
GRADUATED FROM CAL POLY. WITH A
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION DEGREE
AND THROUGHOUT THE SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY AND- DELVED
PLUNGED INTO HIS BUSINESSES
THROUGHOUT SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY. A JUDGE ON FIRST SERVED
AS COUNTY SUPERVISOR. THEN WAS
ELECTED IN WHICH HE WAS ELECTED
TO A NINETY EIGHT UNTIL HE
THEN. WAS ELECTED TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND TEN.
I CAME TO GET BETTER ACQUAINTED
WITH CACHO AFTER I WAS ELECTED-
TWO YEARS LATER- AND JUST ON A
PERSONAL BASIS- THERE'S A
CERTAIN CONNECTION WHERE TO
ARMENIANS MEET ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD. REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY'RE FROM ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY'RE BOTH IMMIGRANTS. HIM
FROM LEBANON AND ME FROM IRAN
JUST THE ASPECT TO ASPECTS.
MANY ARMENIANS HAVE BEEN
SHOCKED AND AROUND THE WORLD
AFTER THE GENOCIDE IN ORDER TO
SURVIVE. AND- SECOND WITH THE
DIFFERENT TUMULTUOUS. REGIMES
THROUGHOUT THE MIDDLE EAST THAT
FORCED MANY OF US BELIEVE OUR
RESPECTIVE COUNTRIES THAT WE
FINALLY SETTLED AND THEN ARRIVE
TO THE UNITED STATES- YOU CAN
IMAGINE THE BURDENS AND
CHALLENGES. FEARS TREPIDATION
AND EVERYTHING THAT'S CARRIED.
SO IT WAS WONDERFUL TO HAVE A
PARTNER WHO UNDERSTOOD EXACTLY
WHAT SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
WERE. AND TO BE ABLE TO PARTNER
UP TOGETHER AND TO MAKE
MEANINGFUL WORK NOT JUST FOR
CALIFORNIA BUT AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SIMPLY OBISPO ELOQUENTLY
SAID. WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
WORLD FROM A PRISM OF TORMENT
AND FIGHT. IF YOU THEN WANT TO
SEEK PEACE AT ALL TIMES. SO IT
WAS NOT AT ALL UNIMAGINABLE HOW
CONCILIATORY- AND HOW- HOW MUCH
HE REVERED BEING ABLE TO GET TO
THE COMMON DENOMINATOR WITH
EVERYONE. AS OPPOSED TO FINDING
AN OPPORTUNITY TO FIGHT. AND
FOR THAT REASON. HE WAS VERY
MUCH RESPECTED BY ALL HIS
COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE AISLE AND
WITHIN HIS OWN PARTY. SO MUCH
SO THAT A CHARGE AND WAS THE
ONLY REPUBLICAN TO BE APPOINTED
AS HE COMMITTEE CHAIR UNDER A
DEMOCRATIC SPEAKER AT LEAST IN
MODERN TIMES. MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SALLY THIS BILL AND I WORKED
SINCE LAST MARCH TO TRY TO FIND
AN- OPPORTUNE TIME. TO HAVE HI
JUST FAMILY. BE HERE WITH US.
SO THAT- WE CAN CELEBRATE AND
HIS LIFE AND HIS CONTRIBUTIONS
WITH THEM. UNFORTUNATELY THAT
WASN'T MEANT TO BE BECAUSE
SINCE MARCH WE JUST WERE NOT
ABLE TO FIND THE APPROPRIATE
TIME- AND GIVEN THIS PANDEMIC
GIVEN THE LOCKDOWN
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE'RE
OPERATING AND- WE COULDN'T HAVE
THEM JOIN US- BUT I WANTED TO.
SEND MY LOVE TO IRAQ SEE HIS
SPOUSE OF THIRTY SIX YEARS SUN
HAT AUCH AND DAUGHTER NAIRI-
AND IN ADDITION TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE SAID BEFORE WITH SUCH
A BEING BELOVED IN. SEMI OBISPO
HE WAS ALSO VERY BELOVED HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
HEIRESSES ERIN MISTER BLOOM
ALSO RECOGNIZE SOME THIS IS
GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK YOU MISS
SPEAKER- AND I JOIN AS THAT WE
HAVE AND MEMORY OF CACHO AS
CHEN ON WITH WHOM I AND OUR
CALL FROM SANTA. SERVED ON THE
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OKAY FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND IF EVER
THERE WAS AN UNLIKELY
FRIENDSHIP IT WOULD BE UP FOR
ME IT WOULD BE SOMEONE WHO'S A
CIGAR SMOKING SUBURBAN DRIVING
GAS STATION OWNING A REPUBLICAN
FRIGHT FESTS LIKE YOU DON'T
THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE A
NATURAL- BUT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS CULTURAL AND I AGREE
TO BE- VERY GOOD FRIENDS.
DURING THE COURSE OF OUR TIME
BOTH ON THE COASTAL COMMISSION
AND HERE AND. IN SACRAMENTO.
EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN SAID
ABOUT- BY MY TO CALL THE BY OUR
CALL. IS ABSOLUTELY. AND THEN
SOME HE WAS A WONDERFUL PERSON
WITH A VERY WARM SPIRIT AND
ALWAYS WANTING TO BE HELPFUL IN
ACCOMPLISHING THINGS IN THE
JEWISH TRADITIONALLY- TYPICALLY
SAY. MAY HIS MEMORY BE FOR A
BLESSING AND WITH SOME PEOPLE
IT'S LIKE YOU KNOW AT LEAST I
HOPE- WITH CACHO. IT'S AN
ABSOLUTE CERTAINTY THAT
EVERYONE HE TOUCHED WAS BLESSED
BY HIM AND WILL BE BLESSED IN
THE FUTURE AND FOR ALL TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER FLOURNOY.
MISTER RAMOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR A GERMAN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE TO
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURNED TODAY
IN THE MEMORY OF HAY SEUSS AS
FAR AS A WHEN YOU LOS. MISTER
WAS NINETY ONE. AND SERVED
FAMILY COMMUNITY AND COUNTRY
WITH GREAT DISTINCTION. HE WAS
A DECORATED VETERAN AND
RESPECTED BUSINESSMAN IN
YUCAIPA. AFTER STARTING WHEN
YOURS CONSTRUCTION CORPORATION
AND MCC PIPELINE. HE WENT TO
HELP FOUND THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION TO PROMOTE MEXICAN
AMERICAN CONSTRUCTION AND
CONTRACTOR FIRMS. TODAY HIS SON
KEN MILLENNIALS CONTINUES HIS
LEGACY AND RUNNING M. C. C.
PIPELINE TODAY WE OWE A LOT TO
MISTER MOON YOURS AND HIS LATE
WIFE VIE WHO ARE TRIED
TRAILBLAZERS AND FOSTERING. THE
CHICANO AND LATINOS AND
POLITICAL ENGAGEMENT IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE. THEY STARTED THE
TICKET SHOULD LATINO CAUCUS OF
THE INLAND EMPIRE. NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR. MANY TIMES WOULD
BE A TO SEE. OF MISTER YOURS
AND VICE AND THEIR BACK. AT ALL
THE DIFFERENT FUNCTION AND SO
TODAY IN THE INLAND EMPIRE. HE
HELP TO STAFF THE YUCAIPA. CLUB
HE INVITE ALSO NEVER FAIL TO
SUPPORT YOUNG PEOPLE AND SERVED
AS A MENTOR TO MANY OF THOSE
WITH THIS HUMBLING HARDWORKING
EXAMPLE A COMMITMENT TO CIVIL
RIGHTS AND GOOD GOVERNMENT.
MANY TIMES IN LIFE PEOPLE COME
ACROSS YOU CROSS PATHS WITH
PEOPLE. THE CROSS THE PAST THAT
WERE THERE WITH THE MUNOZ
FAMILY AND MR WHEN YOURS IN
PARTICULAR HIS SUPPORT TO SEE
SO MANY YOUNG PEOPLE MOVE
FORWARD MOVE FORWARD IN THEIR
LIVES TO BE ABLE TO BELIEVE
THAT THEY CAN MAKE THAT CHANGE
IN OUR COMMUNITY. THIS
FORTUNATE ONLY RUN ACROSS
PEOPLE OF THIS CALIBER. MISTER
MOON YOURS WAS ONE OF THOSE. HE
HELPS SO MANY SO MANY MOVE
FORWARD IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
HOMELESS FAMILIES IN MY
CONDOLENCES TO HIS WHOLE FAMILY
THAT'S THERE. A LEGACY THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO BE BUILT BY
BELIEVING IN PEOPLE THAT THEY
CAN ASPIRE TO MAKE THE CHANGE
IN OUR COMMUNITY JUST LIKE
MISTER MISTER MOON YOU'LL STOOD
WITH HIS WHOLE FAMILY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU
MYSTERONS AND MS RADIUS YOU ARE
ALSO RECOGNIZE HONESTLY GERMAN
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I JOIN MY COLLEAGUE
FROM HIGHLAND IN ASKING THAT WE
TURN MEMORY OF OUR DEAR FRIEND
HAS TO SOMEONE ELSE. HAS SEUSS
WAS A MENTOR LEADER A GUIDE HE
WAS A VETERAN. HE WAS A HERO.
AND IT WAS SO MUCH MORE. HIS
UNSELFISH HE UNSELFISHLY GAVE
OF HIS TIME AND TREASURES TO
MAKE OUR WORLD A BETTER PLACE
HAS SEUSS IS PRECEDED IN DEATH
BY HIS LOVING WIFE VIOLA LYING
WHEN YOU ALSO BY THE LEóN ON
YOUR. A SUSAN VIBE TRAILED IN
THE COMMUTER AND PAUL IS CALL
THE SHARE. THEY FOR IN THE
STAFF THE YOU GONNA **** OF THE
ALL EMPIRE. I FOUR. AN
ORGANISER THAT IS LOCKED IN HAS.
HUNDREDS OF TO GO AND LATINO
CAN GET A TO VERY OFFICES
THROUGHOUT THE INLAND EMPIRE.
AS A DECORATED. HE STILL IN
TOWARD RACIAL INJUSTICES THAT
DID NOT BREAK HIM. AS A
BUSINESSMAN HE PROVED THE VALUE
OF HARD WORK AND PERSISTENCE AS
A COMMUNITY LEADER HE PROVED
THE POWER OF UP LOOK FOR THE
UPLIFTING OTHERS. AS A FRIEND
HE WAS LOYAL TO THE CHICANO
MOVEMENT AND THE NEED TO
EMPOWER OUR YOUTH. WE WILL MISS
HIM. MAY HE REST IN ETERNAL
PEACE WITH VIçT AT HIS SIDE
IN THE GLORY OF OUR FATHER.
THIS IS A SURVIVAL HIS THREE
LOVING CHILDREN HIS SEUSS
MANUALS. BEVOR PURCELL- MANOS
KENNETH KNOWS THIS FOR GRAN.
THIRTEEN GRAND SIX GREAT GREAT
GRAND. AND A HOST OF X. FAMILY
MEMBERS. MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN US
IN A JOINING HIM OF HIS SEUSS
WHEN YOU. THANK YOU ADDRESS.
AND MR MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER FOR YOUR IN GERMANY
MEMBERS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. AND MEMBERS. THE
CAPITAL COMMUNITY LOST ONE OF
OUR OWN RECENTLY. GIORGETTI
MORA SERVED THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE FOR OVER TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS. GEORGETTE WAS ONE
OF THE FIRST ASIANS TO SERVE IN
THIS BUILDING. SHE STARTED OUT
AS A RECEPTIONIST IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEROY GREEN. NOW SHE WORKED HER
WAY UP. SHE SERVED AS
LEGISLATIVE SECRETARY FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YVONNE
BRATHWAITE. LESS THAT OF
ASSISTANT TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JULIAN DIXON. CHIEF OF STAFF TO
SENATOR DIANNE WATSON. STAFF
DIRECTOR FOR THE SENATE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS. PRINCIPAL
CONSULTANT FOR THE SENATE
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. AND SENATE
FLOOR COORDINATOR AND
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR SENATE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM DAVID REVERDY.
I FIRST MET GEORGE AT ALMOST
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AGO. IN THE
SUMMER OF NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
WHEN I WAS AN UNDERGRAD AT
BERKELEY AND AN INTERN. AT THE
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS IN OAKLAND
CHINATOWN. THIS WAS A TIME WHEN
THERE WERE NO ASIAN STATE
LEGISLATORS. AND FEW ASIAN
STAFF. WORKING IN THIS BUILDING.
GEORGETTE AND HER LONGTIME
PARTNER IN CRIME MAYBE TOM. AT
BEST THAT TIME CAME TO ANNOUNCE
THEIR CREATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE'S FIRST
OFFICE OF ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AFFAIRS. WITH THIS
MOVE GEORGETTE AND MAINLY OPEN
THE DOORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE TO ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. MANY OF
US LEGISLATORS AND STAFF WOULD
NOT ADVANCE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE IN THIS BUILDING WITHOUT
THE PRIOR NEARING WORK OF WOMEN
LIKE GEORGETTE A MORA.
GEORGETTE WAS BORN IN THE
MANZANAR CONCENTRATION CAMP
DURING WORLD WAR TWO. AND SHE
NEVER FORGOT WHERE SHE CAME
FROM. SHE DEDICATED HER ENTIRE
LIFE TO FIGHT FOR CIVIL RIGHTS
AND TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITY.
THERE ARE SEVERAL MEMBERS ON
THIS FLOOR WHO ARE PART IN
GEORGE'S LEGACY. SHE ALONG WITH
MAINLY AND MANY MANY OTHER
AMAZING PEOPLE STARTED THE API
LESSON OF CAUCUS INSTITUTE'S
CAPITAL ACADEMY TO RECRUIT AND
TRAIN A. P. I. CANDIDATES TO
RUN FOR STATE OFFICE. I WAS IN
THE CAPITAL ACADEMY CLASS I
BELIEVE IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES ROB
BONTA AND MY FORMER COLLEAGUE
TYLER DEEP. WE WOULD NOT BE
HERE WITHOUT THE WORK OF GEORGE
AT MRO. GEORGETTE IS SURVIVED
BY HER HUSBAND OF OVER FIFTY
FIVE YEARS ROY. THEIR TWO SONS
TODD AND ERIN. AND MANY MANY
OTHER FRIENDS AND FAMILY TODAY
I RISE TO HONOR AND TO THANK
GIORGETTI MORE A FOR HER MANY
YEARS OF SERVICE AND FOR MAKING
A DIFFERENCE IN OUR LIVES.
THANK YOU MAYES MURATSUCHI
MISTER COULD EURO RECKON ON
THIS IN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO
WITH TO GET MY RESPECT IN
DEEPER THE TO THE FAMILY
FRIENDS INTO THOSE US WITH OF
WORKING WITH PROJECT IN YOUR-
DURING A TWENTY ACRE. IN THE
CAP. THEY'RE JUST IS A STORY OF.
BORN JAPANESE CONCEPT CAMP ALSO
SEGMENT. GEORGETTE GREW UP
DURING ERA THAT SHOWED ONE
AMERICA UGLY SIDES OF RACISM.
BUDGET TOOK THE EXPIRY IN LEAD
A LIFE THE CIVIL ACTIVISTS
FIGHTING FOR THE RIGHTS NOT
JUST THE API. WILL ALSO ALL
UNDER REPRESENT CAN. AS A
LONGTIME MILLIE THOMPSON. WHEN
SHE FOUGHT SHE FOR WITH
EVERYTHING SHE HAD. SHE NEVER
DID. HALFWAY AT RETIRING TO
SIX. MURDA VOTED WRITTEN. TO
SERVING IN THE API COMMUNITY.
AS A VOLUNTEER SERVING THE BALL
OF CALIFORNIA IS PACIFIC UNDER.
CAUCUS IN. CAP IN ASIAN LEGAL
FOR. OUT OF REACH. I GEORGIANNE
BRIDGETTE. FIRMER COMMUNITY
WERE HER HUSBAND ROLE. THEM THE
POP- ISSUE. NO DOUBT IN MY MIND
THAT CALIFORNIA IS A BETTER
PLACE BECAUSE OF MISTER MIRACLE
AND A DEDICATION TO FIGHTING
THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF ALL OF US.
WITH THE MISSOURI SURVIVOR. OI
ENTER TWO SONS TODD AND AARON.
MY HEARTFELT PRAYERS GO OUT TO
HER FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND TO
THE ENTIRE API COMMUNITY THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADJOURN IN GEORGIA THE NEAREST
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER COOPER
AND MR TANG YOUR ALSO
RECOGNIZED ON THE SHERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ALSO JOIN MY COLLEAGUES
IN. RISING TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF GEORGETTE AMORA.
SIMILAR TO. MY COLLEAGUE FROM
PALACE VERDES. I MET GEORGETTE
WHEN I WAS STILL IN COLLEGE AT
UC BERKELEY. PROBABLY IN THE
SPRING OF NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE.
AT THAT TIME LIKE MANY OTHER
BERKELEY STUDENTS WE WOULD COME
UP TO THE CAPITAL TO MEET WITH
LEGISLATORS AND TO MEET WITH
STAFF AND- AS MY COLLEAGUE
EARLIER STATED THERE WERE NO
ASIAN LEGISLATORS TO BE WHERE.
BECAUSE AT THAT TIME ASIAN
AMERICANS DIDN'T HAVE ANY
REPRESENTATION AMONGST THE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY. ELECTED
MEMBERS OF THIS LEGISLATURE.
BUT IT WAS FOR MEETING WITH HER.
EMILY TOM WITH A POINT WHERE
BOTH WORK FOR CENTER PRO TEM.
FAVORABLE THAT WAS ONE OF OUR
HIGH BECAUSE IT ACTUALLY WAS
NOT FOR TO MEET. AND ACTUALLY
SEE ASIAN OF. WERE IN THE STATE.
COULD I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT
YOUR- DECIDED TO WORK IN THIS
CAPITAL B. SHE KNEW WHAT IT
FELT LIKE DECISIONS ARE MADE OF
YOU. YOUR FAMILY AND YOUR
COMMUNITY. WITHOUT YOUR
INVOLVEMENT BECAUSE IT WAS THIS
VERY DECISION DURING WORLD WAR
TWO THAT SET HER AND HER FAMILY
HER COMMUNITIES INTO INTERNMENT
CAMPS NOT JUST IN CALIFORNIA
BUT REALLY ALL AROUND THE
COUNTRY MISTAKE THAT WE HAVE
COME TO ACKNOWLEDGE THEM THAT
WE CONTINUE TO PAY THE PRICE
FOR. BUT IT WAS THAT DRIVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE WAS ACCESS.
BUT THERE WAS OPENNESS
TRANSPARENCY THAT THEIR RIGHTS
THAT YOU HAD TO BE. IN THE ROOM
WITH THE DECISIONS WERE BEING
MADE. AND FOR ME AT THAT TIME
WHEN I FIRST VISITED HER IN
SENATOR BIRDIES OFFICE I COULD
NEVER IMAGINE WE'RE NEVER DID
REALLY IMAGINE MYSELF- EVER
WORKING IN THE CAPITAL. OR
FRANKLY BEING A MEMBER OF THIS
ESTEEMED BODY. BUT IT WAS
REALLY BECAUSE OF HER DRIVE.
HER LEADERSHIP. FOR SO MANY OF
US THAT WE SAW SOME PATH TO
SACRAMENTO. AND THAT WE KNEW IT
WAS NOT JUST ABOUT REPRESENTING
OUR OWN INDIVIDUAL VOICE BUT WE
ARE COMMUNITIES WORSE. THAN
BEING THERE AS A FIGHTER FOR
OUR COMMUNITY. THE FOR ALL THE
VERY ISSUES THAT UP IN TERMS OF
CIVIL RIGHTS. SO I ALSO WANT TO
RISE AND JUST THINK GEORGIA
BURKE IN TURN OF. EVERYTHING
SHE HAS MEANT TO ME PERSONALLY.
BUT ALSO IN TERMS OF HER HUGE
ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. AND THE INFORMED
SHE'S HALF IN THIS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHANG. AND MR FROM THE
REAR THE THANK YOU. YOU ARE
ALSO RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I TO RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF GEORGETTE
HIMURA. GEORGETTE HAD A LONG
AND TRAILBLAZING CAREER IN THIS
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE.
HE STARTED WORKING IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE LATE
NINETEEN SIXTIES AS A SENATE
RECEPTIONIST. THIS WAS THE TIME
WHEN THE REPRESENTATION AND
INCLUSION OF ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS IN THESE HALLOWED
HALLS WITH LITTLE. TO NONE. AS
A WOMAN IN THE WORLD OF
POLITICS YOU DEFIED ALL ODDS.
AND SHE BROKE NUMEROUS GLASS
AND BAMBOO CEILINGS RISING TO
THE RANK OF CHIEF OF STAFF.
GEORGETTE DEVOTED HERSELF TO
PAVING A PATH FOR MORE API
REPRESENTATION IN CALIFORNIA
POLITICS FOR LEGACY IS
ENSHRINED AND CEMENTED IN THE
PROGRAMS SHE FOUNDED LIKE THE
ASIAN PACIFIC YOUTH LEADERSHIP
PROJECT. TO PROGRAMS LIKE THIS
SHE TOUCHED MANY LIVES WITH HER
HUMBLE WISE AND LOVING
MENTORSHIP. THIS SERVICE AND
MENTORSHIP CONTINUED EVEN AFTER
SHE RETIRED. I HAD THE HONOR OF
MEETING GEORGE AT THE CAPITOL
ACADEMY TRAINING PROGRAM. SHE
WAS ALREADY A GOOD FRIEND OF
AND COMMUNITY PARTNER WITH MY
MOTHER CYNTHIA. IN HERSTORY OF
BEING BORN IN THE MANZANAR
CONCENTRATION CAMP TO WORKING
IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
INSPIRED ME. GEORGETTE WAS
INCREDIBLY WARM COMPASSIONATE
AND KIND. BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE
SHE WAS ALSO FIERCE POWERFUL
AND OUTSPOKEN ESPECIALLY WHEN
SHE ADVOCATED FOR THE VOICELESS
AND FOUGHT FOR THE
DISADVANTAGED. FOR LEGACY IS
ONE ABOUT WHICH SO MANY OF US
CARE DEEPLY. I HOPE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO OF OPENING DOORS
FOR GREATER API REPRESENTATION
IN OUR POLITICAL AND DEMOCRATIC
INSTITUTIONS AND CREATING
OPPORTUNITY. WHEN PREVIOUSLY
THERE WAS NOT. I ASK THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
GEORGETTE IN ORDER. THANK YOU
MR BONTA AND MISTER SPEAKER YOU
ARE ALSO RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS
I TO RISE TO JOIN IN THE
REQUEST FOR THE ASSEMBLY TO
ADJOURN TODAY IN MEMORY OF
GEORGIA AMARA. GEORGETTE WAS A
FAMILIAR FIGURE TO MANY OF US
SHE WAS ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE IN
OUR LEGISLATIVE FAMILY. WENT
FAR BEYOND JUST TAKING CARE OF
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS GEORGETTE
WAS A TRUE LEADER WHO IS STRONG
FIERCE AND NEVER AFRAID TO
FIGHT FOR JUSTICE. SHE WAS A
MENTOR TO COUNTLESS CAPITOL
STAFFERS AND A FRIEND TO MANY
IN THE SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY
INCLUDING MY WIFE ANNE. IN FACT
MY WIFE WAS DRIVING TO
GEORGETTE'S HOME WHEN SHE FOUND
OUT THAT THAT GEORGETTE HAD
PASSED AWAY. HAVING EXPERIENCED
THE INJUSTICES OF MANZANAR AND
HAVING RISEN THROUGH THE
STAFFING RANKS TO THE TOP.
GEORGETTE KNEW THE IMPORTANCE
OF HELPING OTHERS. SHE WIELDED
HER INFLUENCE WITH GREAT
HUMILITY. AND HAD A CAPACITY TO
MAKE OTHERS FEEL THAT THEY WERE
THE IMPORTANT ONES IN THE ROOM.
NOT HER. AS A GREAT MENTOR TO
MANY SHE WILL LIVE ON IN THE
SUCCESSES OF THOSE SHE
FOSTERED. SHE INSTILLED IN MANY
OF THEM HER COMMITMENT TO TURN
AROUND AND HELP THE NEXT
GENERATION. BECAUSE OF THAT
MANY OF THEM HAVE GONE ON TO
FOUND NEW ORGANIZATIONS TO GIVE
OTHERS A HAND UP. MEMBERS I ASK
THAT WE EMBRACE THE SPIRIT. AS
WE ADJOURNED TODAY IN MEMORY OF
GEORGETTE MRO. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. MISTER GIBSON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR THE
CHAMBER FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE ****
BODY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
REVEREND DR DAVID L. TATE. HE
WAS BORN THE SEVENTH OF
FOURTEEN CHILDREN IN
MISSISSIPPI. ON MARCH THE
TWENTY SEVENTH NINETEEN THIRTY
NINE AND NINETEEN SIXTY THREE
HE DEDICATED DEDICATED- THE NEW
CHAPTER IN MOVING TO LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA WHERE HE
JOINED THE UNION BAPTIST CHURCH
WHERE HE RECEIVED HIS CALLING
TO THE MINISTRY. AND ALSO HE
WAS ORDAINED AS A MINISTER AT
THAT CHURCH AS WELL. IT WAS
THERE THAT HE MET AND MARRIED
HIS ONE TRUE LOVE SERETIDE. WHO
THEY BARED FIVE CHIP FIVE
BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN- TOGETHER
REVEREND TATE HAS OVER THIRTY
YEAR CAREER IN THE ERROL
AIRCRAFT INDUSTRY. BEFORE HE-
STARTED- PASTORING FULL TIME
WHICH WAS HIS REAL CALLING IN
LIFE. AS A AS HE WAS PASSIONATE
ABOUT RAISING AND ELEVATING THE
NAME OF JESUS CHRIST AND HIS
CONGREGATION IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO HE MOVED HIS CHURCH TO
PERMANENT LOCATION IN COMPTON
CALIFORNIA WHERE HIS MINISTRY
GROUP. OVER HIS MINISTRY GROUP
AS WELL AS HE SERVED AS SENIOR
PASTOR FOR FIFTY THREE YEARS
EVEN THE FINAL DAYS HE STILL
RAISES HAND TO PRAISE GOD. AND
WORSHIP GOD. EVEN WHEN HE HE
WAS SICK REVERENT TAKE PASSED
ON THESE IS THAT. TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THE A LARGE FAMILIES
LOVED HIM MEMBERS I RESPECT ASK
WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
REVEREND DR DAVID L. TATE.
THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON AND YOU
ARE I CAN RECKON FOR AN
ADDITIONAL MEMORY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AGAIN I HAVE THE BODY
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF DR
WILLIE- JONES DR WILLIE JONES
WAS BORN IN LOUISIANA ON MARCH
EIGHTEENTH NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE. AND WAS THE YOUNGEST OF
SEVEN CHILDREN HE LATER MOVED
TO COME TO THE CITY OF COMPTON
WHERE HE SOUGHT TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF PEOPLE IN HIS
COMMUNITY. DR JONES SERVED AS
THE CITY COUNCIL MEMBER.
REPRESENTING THE FOURTH
DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF COMPTON
ALSO HE SERVED ON THE COUNTER
COMMITTEE COLLEGE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES WAS THE VICE CHAIR OF
THE STUDENT AFFAIRS AS WELL AS-
THE DIRECTOR OF THE FINANCIAL
AID ACCOUNT TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DR JONES. DEVOTED HIS
LIFE AND ACTIVISM AS A
CHRISTIAN MAN WITH GREAT FAITH
AND HE LIVED HIS FAITH EACH AND
EVERY DAY. HE BROUGHT TO LIGHT
INTO EVERY SITUATION A STORY
AND GAVE UNDERSTANDING AND
WHOLE GOD FIRST FAMILY
COMMUNITY SERVICE AND
EDUCATION. WHERE IS PARAMOUNT
TO IMPROVE PARAMOUNT FOR DOCTOR
WILLIE JONES THAT HE AND BODY
THAT WERE HE WENT HE NEVER
STOPPED WORKING TOWARDS
SOMETHING GREATER. DR JONES.
LEAVE THE CHAIR HIS MEMORY
THREE CHILDREN. A DAY. FIVE
BRANCH. AND A WHOLE HOST OF
FRIENDS AND FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
WILL LIVE. ON IN HIS MEMORY.
MEMBERS ASKS IF YOU PLEASE JOIN
IN MEMORY OF DR WILLIE- JONES
FORMER CITY COUNCILMEMBER CITY
OF COMPTON. THANK YOU MISS
GIPSON. A MISTER MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR GERMAN A MEMORY
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF MY FRIEND.
COUNCILWOMAN DR CARLA THORTON.
FROM THE CITY OF MORENO VALLEY.
DR THORTON PASSED ON THURSDAY
JANUARY TWENTY FIRST.
COUNCILWOMAN THORTON WAS BORN
IN CULVER CITY AND GRADUATED
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF MARYLAND
EARNING A BACHELORS OF ARTS
DEGREE IN SOCIAL SCIENCE. SHE
ALSO EARNED A MASTER OF ARTS
DEGREE IN MANAGEMENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS AND A
MASTER OF SOCIAL WORK DEGREE
AND DOCTORATE OF SOCIAL WORK AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. HER DOCTORAL
RESEARCH FOCUS ON WOMEN
VETERANS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. CHALLENGES
AFFECTING THE INLAND EMPIRE. DR
THORTON PROUDLY SERVED OUR
COUNTRY AS A MEMBER OF THE
UNITED STATES AIR FORCE FOR
TWENTY YEARS. SHE DEPLOYED
TWICE IN SUPPORT OF OPERATION
OPERATION ENDURING FREEDOM AND
RETIRED AT THE RANK OF MASTER
SERGEANT. COUNCILMAN THORTON
WAS ELECTED TO HER FIRST FOUR
YEAR TERM IN DECEMBER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WAS THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN TO SERVE
ON THE MARINO VALLEY CITY
COUNCIL. SHE WAS AN ACADEMIC BY
PROFESSION AND SERVED AS
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR AT CAL
BAPTIST UNIVERSITY WHERE SHE
SPECIALIZED IN TEACHING SOCIAL
WORK MANAGEMENT AND POLICY. HER
PASSION IS A TREMENDOUS LOSS
FOR MARINO VALLEY COUNCILMAN
THORTON WAS A DEDICATED PUBLIC
SERVANT WHO CARE DEEPLY FOR THE
PER RESIDENTS IN HER DISTRICT I
ASKED THE WE ADJOURNED AND HER
MEMORY. THANK YOU MR MEDINA AND
THANK YOU MEMBERS. WE TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
FEBRUARY SECOND CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY
THIRD CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY
FEBRUARY FOURTH. YOUR SESSION
IS AT NINE AM ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE HOUSE RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING HEARING OR FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. MS REYES
MOOSE. AND MS FREEMAN SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
FEBRUARY FOURTH AT NINE AM AND
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.